- Welcome, welcome into another
edition of "Market Takes".
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you are here with me
and I appreciate that.
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the "Wall Street Journal".
Today we are digging
into the latest existing
home sales report,
talking about and
explaining what's going on
with the housing market right now.
Existing home sales we know are about 80%
of the overall housing market.
So as we talk through this report
we're gonna talk through
the big picture in housing.
We're gonna talk about what
the report said, obviously,
and how that compared to expectations.
Then we're gonna talk about how this fit
with other recent housing
reports that we've seen.
We talked a little bit about
this on Monday's look ahead,
looking forward to this week's data.
We're gonna talk about how this fits
with the current Inflation narrative.
Take a little look at what's
going on in the markets.
And then talk about what comes next.
Because this report and how it fits
into everything else that's going on
is gonna tell us some important things
about what's going on with the economy
and also what's going on with
the overall housing market.
So let's get into that.
First things first, I want to talk
about today's report and
what the report said.
So wanna throw up here
a chart on your screen
so you can just see for yourself
what we've got going
on in the markets now.
As you see there, those last four reports,
you see there was a clear
trend moving downward
and then the numbers started to pick up
and those bars get a little bit higher
as we moved into 2023.
So for May, you saw
4.3 million homes sold.
That's that last bar there on your screen.
Existing home sales rose 0.2%.
They were expected to drop 0.9%.
So economists were expecting
that declining trend that we had seen
coming into this year to pick up again.
And we had seen those two
reports in a row come negative.
But this really reverses that trend.
And we saw home sales rise slightly.
We also saw prices rise just
a little bit to $396,000.
The average existing home
sold for about $396,000,
up from $395,000 a month ago.
Now, one thing that you're gonna
hear a lot about from folks
is this was the biggest
one year drop since 2011.
But if you look up there on
your screen and you go back
about a year, get to the
middle of that 2022 number,
well you see where those bars are
isn't really that different.
The decline was in prices,
and the decline in
terms of number of sales
wasn't that great.
So this chart really just illustrating
that we are seeing, again,
a pickup in the number of used homes sold
or the number of existing homes sold,
and we are not seeing the continuation
of that declining number.
That was what the Fed wants to see.
We'll get into why the
Fed wants to see that
in just a moment.
When we talk about prices, right,
there was the biggest
drop in prices since 2011.
That's what I was referring
to a little bit earlier.
The biggest year over year drop in prices.
But that year over year drop in prices
was from $408,000 to $396,000.
Think about it, if you're
going out to buy a home,
that's not a big difference.
It's only about a 3.1% drop.
It's just because generally speaking,
home prices have not declined
since 2011 very much.
So a 3.1% drop is the biggest
drop we've seen since 2011.
That should just tell you, listen,
that's not really a big deal.
And that's a year over year decline.
So in one year, prices drop
3.1%, you kinda shrug that off
if you're someone who's
thinking about buying a home
or especially if you're
someone who's thinking
about selling a home, that
really doesn't matter to you.
The momentum stalling
out here really suggests
that we could have hit a floor.
Now, what the Fed wants is for home sales
to continue to drop because
it makes rent prices drop.
With those higher rates, with higher rates
of about double where
they were a little more
than a year ago or a year and a half ago
there is an expectation that
you're gonna see, you know,
home sales falling off a cliff.
That hasn't happened.
They've declined a lot
from those huge highs,
from those big highs we
saw in 2021 and into 2022.
But you're not seeing it fall off a cliff.
We're still above four
million sales per month.
So that's a big deal.
Also, the decline in the number
of homes sold year over year
seems to be flattening out.
Now this is 20% lower
than the number of homes
that were sold a year ago, but again,
that trend is flattening.
So in May, 2022, there's
about 20% less homes sold
in May '23 than there were in May '22,
but that's about the same as
the previous three months.
You saw a 23% decline the month before,
22.1% the month before,
and 23.1% decline the month before that.
All that to say it was
just rocketing lower.
You saw declines each month
getting bigger and bigger,
down to a 37% year over
year drop at the beginning
of the year in January.
And that's reversed course
and now we're only about a 20% drop.
So again, it's lower.
There are less sales, certainly,
but the decline looks to be tapering off.
All that to say that we
have just really seen
a flattening out of this trend.
It's not picking back up yet,
but there are reasons to believe
that that could be happening
when we look at some of the other data.
Now earlier this week we got
the NAHB Housing Market Index
and housing starts data.
Both of those reports came in
much stronger than expected.
Wanna put up here on your screen
the NAHB Housing Market index.
That came in this past
month beating expectations,
and the trends you see on
your screen now is that index.
And that's an index of
sentiment as well as sales.
And it factors in new
home sales a lot more.
But this is really about
home builders, right?
Are folks going out and
building more homes?
Are they excited to build homes?
And as you can see there,
there is a clear pickup
and we've seen it since
the start of this year.
Every month you've seen
since the start of this year
that index has picked up,
and now we're back at the
highest level that we have seen
on that index since May of 2022.
You also have seen new home
sales start to pick up.
And this is why maybe you
could start seeing a bit
of a renaissance in the housing market
if this trend starts to pick up.
And this chart is really illustrating
that rising sentiment that
we've seen so far this year
in the housing market in terms of,
especially that new home sales market.
Housing starts were
actually expected to decline
but rose by 22%.
So a huge increase in the number of houses
that are going to be built.
Contracts are are laid out
there and folks saying, okay,
we're gonna go out and build a new house.
Those jumped by 22% last month,
expected to decline and
we got instead a reversal.
So when we look at the new home sales,
up about 12% year over year
and about 4% on the month.
683,000 homes sold so that
gives you an idea of the scale.
Only about 700 new homes sold
compared to 4.3 million
existing homes sold.
That shows you there's a
lot more existing homes
than new homes to be sold.
We look at April's big
month over month gain,
that's evidence that this
construction of new homes
is really starting to pick up.
But that's largely
because there's just
very little inventory.
Inventory is still at historic lows
in the existing housing market.
The sale of new homes is
about seven and a half months.
You got about seven and a half months
of the normal pace of sales for new homes.
For existing homes it's
at just three months.
And to give you an idea of
historically where that is,
that number of existing homes supply
peaked at about 12 months
of supply back in 2010.
So in 2010, we're coming
off the, you know,
the 2008 global financial
crisis, which was set off
by the mortgage market crisis
and the big busts you had
there, and really a lot of homes
were being listed and put on the market
and there weren't a lot of buyers.
Well, we had a record low
of 1.7 months of supply
in January of 2022, that's the low.
So we're up from the low
at three months right now,
but still very far away from that high
of 12 months of supply
that we saw in 2010.
And really between 2010 and 2022,
you just saw that market just
kind of decline in terms of
the amount of months
of supply on the market
that just really kind of fell.
And we got from that 12
number to that 1.7 number,
basically two months of
supply on the market.
We are seeing a continued
trend of higher housing sales
on the new home side, but
we are not seeing that
on the existing home side.
We're seeing a flattening out.
NAR, the National Association of Realtors
Chief Economist Lawrence
Yun said something
I thought was really interesting
in today's existing home sales report.
He said, quote, "Newly
constructed homes are selling
at a pace reminiscent
of pre pandemic times
because of abundant
inventory in that sector.
However, existing home sales
activity is down sizably
due to the current
supply being roughly half
of the level of 2019."
So really what we're seeing
is a problem of supply,
not enough supply, but
still lots of demand.
That's not what the Fed wants.
The Fed wants to reduce demand.
The Fed's goal is to make you and I,
people who might want to
go out and buy a home,
say you know what, man,
I wanna buy a house,
but these rates are too high.
Oh, it's gonna cost me
so much money to go out
and get a mortgage, I'd rather not.
I'd rather just rent, you know,
or stay in my current place where I am.
Well, that doesn't seem to be happening.
There still is a lot of
demand out there for housing
and there's just not supplies.
So folks are still going out looking,
they're still on Zillow,
they're still scrolling,
they're still going out and you know,
hitting those open houses
and things like that.
But they're just not buying
because they're not
finding anything that is
in their price range or that they like
or that they can afford,
because you know, rates are so high.
But also home prices are still high.
We're down 3.1% from what was
near record highs a year ago.
So again, we're still
seeing all the problems
that were existing in the
housing market continue.
And now we're starting to
see those existing home sales
level off and not fall anymore.
That could play a big
role in overall inflation.
So when we talk about inflation
we've gotta take a look at the CPI,
the Consumer Price Index.
Wanna put that chart up here
on your screen right now.
So when you're talking about the trend,
and that's what always matters,
you see there from the beginning of 2021,
and I wanted to compare this
to that existing home sales
chart that I showed you before.
It just rises up.
And then since that peak
in the middle of 2022
you see there on your screen,
inflation has just continued to come down.
It's consistently declined
every month really since then.
And you see that nice wave pattern down.
That's not what you see
from the existing home sales report.
That's showing it comes down,
but then it picks up again
and now we're plateauing
at that higher level.
Wanted to just show the CPI chart
to illustrate the way
that inflation has moved
and how that's different from
overall existing home sales.
Housing is the biggest
component of core CPI,
which has held above 5%.
Housing is about 40%
of that core CPI number
that the Fed watches.
So really this is telling
us right now that inflation,
while it's been coming down consistently,
the trend that we are seeing in home sales
is not going along with
that and falling as well.
And we could be seeing a leading indicator
of inflation stalling out
or maybe even picking back
up if inflation follows
that NAHB Housing Market
index that I showed you
just a little bit earlier.
Things to watch out for.
However, our realtime
indicators are telling us
that rent prices are going down.
CoreLogic showed single family rent slowed
to only a gain of 3.7% year over year.
Now in April, that tells
you it's still rising.
Rent is still rising
according to CoreLogic.
But that's down from about 14% increases
at the same time in 2022.
All US metros in the CoreLogic
survey posted an increase
of just single digits or less.
So that shows you that the inflation
is coming down in rents,
except for Las Vegas,
that was the one which
posted a small annual loss.
Rent.com survey actually
showed a -0.57% drop
in annual prices.
So we are seeing rents decline, but again,
as housing prices go up and
as those rates stay high,
landlords, owners are
going to have to pay more
and they're gonna pass that
cost on to tenants, renters,
et cetera, et cetera.
And so we could start to
see those rental prices
continuing to pick back up.
Now what I wanna do right
now is let's take a look
at the markets.
I wanna throw this up here on
your screen and just show you
what we're looking at in
the markets right now.
This is an overview of what
we're looking at on wsj.com.
You see the DOW is down about 0.2%,
the S&P about flat on the day,
the NASDAQ holding up
about half a percent.
I thought what was really interesting
is crude you're seeing
here is down about 5%.
Gold is down about 1%.
So we've got some interesting
moves going on in the market.
I think you saw a big
pickup when you look up here
at the NASDAQ and some of
these other stock indexes
that you were seeing.
Computer's running a little
slow, apologize for that.
But you did see a pickup right
around that 10 o'clock number
with this number of existing home sales.
And really it seems
like the market is just kind
of bullishly moving upward.
And this just illustrating
the kind of trends
that we have seen and are
seeing from the market,
especially stocks which seem to be biased
to move to the upside.
It'll be interesting to
see where we end today
because the NASDAQ up
over 30% year to date,
we are seeing some very interesting things
in terms of the market.
So listen, let's talk
about big picture takeaways
from this report.
Big picture takeaway number one,
don't be fooled by the headlines.
You're gonna see folks,
and I've already seen this,
biggest annual drop in pricing since 2011.
Oh my gosh, the housing
market is falling off a cliff.
Don't believe the hype.
I'm telling you right now,
it's just a 3.1% drop.
It's the biggest drop
that we've seen since 2011
because mostly housing prices just go up.
So it's unusual for them to go down.
But that decrease you're
seeing, not a major decrease.
Not anything that anyone is
really gonna get excited about,
especially with mortgage
rates still around 7%.
The pace of home sales is
lower than recent history
but it is not falling off a cliff.
We are not seeing home sales cooperating
with what the Fed wants to do.
We are not seeing a decline in demand.
Last but not least,
I think the biggest
surprise in the report was
that it just shows how strong
the demand for housing is.
Prices still near record highs,
rates have doubled since 2021,
but sales are not falling.
This could be bad news for
what the Fed wants to do
on inflation because we know
they watch that core number.
We know that core CPI, core PCE,
those two big inflation
gauges that the Fed watches
and talks about
are very tied to what's going
on in the housing market
and very tied to what's going on
with how people are paying for shelter.
What comes next?
Well, we are gonna be right
here on "Market Takes"
10:00 AM Eastern on Monday morning.
I hope you'll be with us for that.
Next week we'll be talking
about the new home sales report.
I think that's gonna be big.
Does it continue to show this trend
of much higher sales, much higher prices,
and what does that tell
us about inflation?
Also, the PCE report,
which has been, you know,
hasn't really been in the news that much.
We've been talking about CPI.
But I think this PCE report
would be very interesting
because it's gonna tell us, you know,
where is the Fed's favorite
gauge of inflation moving?
It actually rose last month
while CPI continued that decline
that I showed you on your screen.
So if PCE rises again,
that could really be big news to the Fed.
I'll tell you all about
that on Monday at 10:00 AM.
Listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on "Market Takes".
We'll be back with you
Monday at 10:00 AM Eastern.
I hope you'll be with us and
we will see you next time.